that doesn't sound like a recession to
me thank you very much
[Music]
all right internet
this
is
it
it is july 29th in the year 2022
it is friday
which means that it is the last work day
of the month before august and yours
truly your favorite youtube host
dave rubin is going off the grid for
august so this is a very special live
stream we're probably gonna go for a
couple hours we got announcements we got
giveaways we've got a yearly recap we've
got so much more my god it's going to be
nuts
i'm very excited to be here the team is
pumped today everyone is feeling good
everyone's about to take a little time
off i i gave them projects and things to
do throughout august but in many ways
this is what our whole year leads to it
leads to this time just to get off the
machines to be humans to see family
perhaps to
take a walk to do other
things and you know as you guys know
this will now be my fit this is my fifth
or my sixth this is the fifth
we had to check this morning because
i've been doing this for a while now so
this is my fifth
off the grid august
oh and i shouldn't mention by the way
it's my sister's birthday and my sister
works for us great lady and she's eight
months pregnant tal happy birthday i
wish you happy birthday in person too
but you know here we go it's the
internet uh so you know when i started
doing this off the grid thing it really
was just sort of a joke i kind of did it
as just like could it be done like could
i throw my phone in a safe could i not
look at my computer could i not
check the news not look at my ipad just
get off all the stuff because the
internet we all know it's like they gave
us social media and we thought it was
gonna make us
more social and in many ways it's made
us more crazy it's like it's the
catch-22 of the internet and the
internet really is a tool and a tool can
be used for good or bad a hammer can you
know
hammer in a nail and then you know your
house doesn't fall down or you can use a
hammer to crack someone's skull
sometimes someone's attacking you and
you want to crack their skull that's a
good use of a hammer sometimes you're
murdering somebody not a good use of a
hammer so that's what the internet is
and they gave us social media we thought
it was going to make us more social but
we know it made us more anxiety-ridden
and angry and crazy and and frustrated
with strangers and then this cancel
culture thing and all this stuff so when
i did this a couple years ago i kind of
saw all that i guess early i suppose and
that's probably directly connected to my
political evolution as well
and i was like let me just try let me
just try it and i tried it one year and
it was freaking amazing um you know the
year that i tried it also was coming off
a year when my career was really blowing
up i had done that while i left the left
video
suddenly i was getting all this endless
hate from the lefties and as you guys
know i developed from all the the stress
of all of that which i wasn't dealing
with well and i was getting death
threats you know from the tolerant
diverse lefty the nice people uh it was
before we called them wokesters or
whatever
i developed alopecia areata i had lost
like 40 percent of my hair just falling
out in chunks i was on this crazy
experimental medication i get into all
this and don't burn this book um and i
was like i just want to try something i
just want to try to get off this thing
like it's a lark let's just see if it
can even be done can a human do it
people are afraid to get offline for
literally a day or a weekend
um and i did it and it was incredible
and we traveled a little bit and we just
didn't do much people always ask me well
what do you do
i don't know i don't do much
we've we've traveled we've done some
pretty awesome vacations we've done some
rainforest things in mexico we've done
the bora bora over the water just
staring out into oblivion thing i catch
up on some reading or i don't read
anything i literally will just kind of
like just stare at the ocean for a
couple hours a day really have my coffee
just enjoy
life and air and take a lot of walks and
all that good stuff and that's why i
started doing it and i really truly
believe
that one of the reasons that i've stayed
sane while doing politics because i have
no doubt that
i know you don't want me to know this
but i'm probably not the only show you
watch there are other internet people
doing internet politics shows
but a lot of people go crazy
a lot of people that i've interviewed a
lot of people that i was in cahoots with
they all politics just made it breaks
people and then you know trump
derangement syndrome and all these
things and so many people just become
broken and endlessly obsessed by all
that and you guys know the way i do the
show it's it's to not be broken and
endlessly obsessed by it it's actually
to to know the enough stuff about the
world and about politics so that you can
be happier and live a good life and i
think i've done a pretty good job of
that and it's directly connected to
doing this off the grid thing so uh this
off the grid obviously will be very
different than all the other off the
grids because this off the grid uh we
have a baby arriving could be any day
now any day we were just at the ob gyn
uh two days ago baby is big baby has all
the fingers the nose all the stuff that
a baby has and uh baby's thinking about
coming out so uh it's gonna be very very
different uh we're gonna have a baby
which is a whole big thing and uh i
guess i'm gonna be a dad that's a big
thing and we're gonna have to figure out
i know everyone said you got to catch up
on the sleep so i've been trying to get
ahead on the sleep
uh and so we're not going to be
traveling we're just going to be here
and and kind of shift in
to that next stage of life um and you
know a lot of people have been asking me
how do you feel this is how do you feel
you're gonna be a dad how do you feel
and i have to say it's like i'm not uh
i'm not nervous really like i know we're
gonna be good
uh i know that this baby these babies
because there's another one coming in
october that they're going to be beloved
and surrounded by by great people and
great extended family and all of those
things so i'm not really nervous about
that i think i think david will be
really good at a lot of the sort of
nitty-gritty stuff and you know i'll be
pretty good at uh teaching this kid how
to shoot
basketball and gun actually now that
we're here in florida that was not the
original plan but you know we can do
that too and uh i just think it's going
to be good the one feeling that i've had
i guess that that's worth mentioning um
is that in some ways the last couple
weeks now that we've been getting to the
finish line here it's like we're getting
to the finish line of a certain
life that i've known and especially
these last like five years my life has
been pretty great like i've done what
i've wanted to do i i'm successful i
we've got resources i have great friends
and a team around me and all of those
things like i've accomplished a lot i
built a company and sold a company like
i've become now here in florida like i'm
i'm in with the political people that i
want to be in with like i really did it
somehow i don't even know how i did it
to some degree you just do it and then
you look back and you go boy i guess
something could happen but i do see a
sort of finish line of the life that
i've known
and i see it and it could be tomorrow it
could literally be today i mean i guess
we could get a text
hopefully not while i'm live streaming
today uh that we got to go to the
hospital and it's like i can see that
life kind of closing so in some ways
i've been sort of mourning
the life that i've known and i guess you
know it's kind of interesting because
i'm 46
and you know a lot of people i would say
most people although people are having
children later in life now you know most
people have kids probably in their
mid-20s into their 30s
so that finish line then i'm seeing a
lot of people get to that finish line a
lot younger than me but i'm getting to
that finish line now and i know there
will be great things on the other side
of the finish line after you get on the
other side of that finish line then a
whole other world starts and then there
are many other finish lines along the
way and i guess you're really never
finished until until that last moment
right
um but i have been sort of mourning just
like the good life that i've had and but
also with the knowledge that like
all right it was good and there's
something good on the horizon uh so i'm
very uh i'm very excited for the next
month and uh and i'm excited for what
we're gonna do today because we got a
lot to get to so we're gonna do some uh
some recap over the last year because we
realized a couple days ago as we were
putting this show together we were like
man a lot did happen this year not only
personally moves and politically and
everything else but just like a huge a
tremendous amount happened i i think i
can speak for everyone's room has a year
ever gone by in any of your lives faster
than this like this was nuts like i feel
like i got to florida yesterday it is
just it has just happened faster and
faster and faster and uh all right so
we're gonna do the my favorite moments
the top ten moments
of uh political moments current event
moments of the year since i got back in
last september first uh we're gonna do a
reuben report locals community q a oh
and i should mention that we are doing a
promo today only this is our best deal
of the year we're only doing it for 24
hours only today
if you go to
reubenreport.locals.com or if you go to
reubenreport.com support actually that's
that's the one you should really go to
because code's already in reuben there
it is right there on the screen good man
uh
reubenreport.com support and you sign up
for our locals community annually you
will get three
months free and for a bunch of people we
got a whole bunch of shirts we're moving
merch we got a lot going on in the house
we got to make room for the baby we got
a whole bunch of shirts reuben report
shirts we're just going to send some to
people who sign up today so you can get
the reuben report shirt if you sign up
today we're going to get out as many as
we can i can't promise to everybody that
signs out today signs up today but it's
only if you do the annual membership you
get three months reads reubenreport.com
support and you are good to go and then
you can communicate with us and get
involved in the live chat and you get
videos early and all of that good stuff
okay uh let me talk to you guys about
real estate agents i trust.com real
quick and then we will dive
into what is a big
show today it's a big show can you tell
people it's a big show uh you guys know
that buying or selling a home is already
one of the most stressful things you can
do and it can be 10 times worse if
you're not working with the right agent
generally speaking our homes are our
biggest investment which of course is a
ton of responsibility and you need an
agent who takes that seriously and
that's why i recommend real estate
agents i trust they work with only the
best agents in every market they do
their homework talking to every agent
before inviting them to join their
network and here's a big one they only
work with full-time pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents their team makes
the introduction and then follows you
through the buying or selling process to
make sure that you're satisfied the
agents they work with have long track
records and are the best sellers in
their field they're part of this
audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go over to real estate agents
itrust.com today give them some info
they'll contact you you will move to the
free state of florida and live happily
ever after that is what you will do all
right people if you're just jumping in
on the live stream i'm going off the
grid baby
so we're recapping the year we're going
to do a community q a
i'll make a couple announcements in a
little bit and then i will be back
on september 1st
in
actually i'll tease a little something i
will be in our local studio here in
miami we have been building studios
so that
locals creators including yours truly
can start doing in-person interviews
again you know we did a couple in-person
interviews that we did that we shot here
at my house but
trying to uh especially the kids come
and trying to get some of this stuff out
of my house so uh we built studios they
are they are almost done in miami and
the first thing that will be shot
at local studio will be my back on the
grid show uh which will be on september
1st with a very special guest i don't
want to say who it is but it's a very
special guest so go through your rolodex
of special people and it might be one of
them and uh
that's it all right so let's do uh a
little recap we thought we'd first do a
little recap of what has happened in the
year you know one of the things i'm
always talking to you guys about is
things happen so fast now right and
we're so slammed with social media we're
so slammed at the endless news cycle all
this stuff that we literally forget
things that happened yesterday the week
before the month before the year before
and then they just kind of keep us on
this crazy ride so i think it is good to
look back and say hey what happened in
this past year so first off if we go all
the way back to september
of last year so september of 2021 i got
back on the grid and as you may remember
at that time
california was going through a recall
they were trying to recall gavin newsom
and i got to put some money in the jar
because we will help somebody get out of
cali and move to florida
california was going through the recall
and larry elder of course was the
leading candidate to take out evil
soulless gavin newsom and right when i
got back the recall i believe the day of
the recall was september 11th so we had
about 10 11 days to really push as hard
as we could to really fire up people and
i met i met literally thousands of
people while touring with larry and we
did everything we could to fight didn't
work out the way we wanted but you may
remember this little video from one of
the events that we did back in september
[Music]
nobody is sweating like gavin newsom
right this very moment
[Music]
maxwell where are you i'm hanging with
your mom at the larry elder rally great
lady by the way really fantastic
[Music]
gavin newsom is tweeting this and he's
bringing in his spectacularly loved uh
surrogates like elizabeth warren and amy
klobucharia
he brought in a fake native american
from boston to tell us how we should
live okay
and what they're afraid of is that larry
elder from the hood who went to a public
school will be able to make the case the
black and brown people you are being
betrayed
man i could have teared up while
watching that it was a great we tried we
did everything we could do and and
whether you get that win or not if we
did not get that win and subsequently my
life changed an awful lot after that
which we'll get to in just a moment
it's worth trying it's worth fighting
the good fight and larry who the media
called the black face of white supremacy
and joe biden showed up and refused to
say his name the day before the recall
and called him a trump clone a guy who
was from the hood son of a janitor and
all that stuff it's like it was worth
the fight so that's how the year started
i think i think of my year as sort of a
september
to august year that's how the year kind
of kicked off like a school year for us
and uh it was worthy three days after
the recall failed uh i was audited by
the state of california and i believe
that was the day i said to david i'm
leaving this [ __ ] you can come with
me if you'd like but i'm getting out of
here and then very quickly uh we started
putting the pieces together to escape
and get to the free state of florida uh
october we're doing one thing for each
month october was a huge month uh for
everything that i had been working on
for a long long time because rumble
and locals officially merged i think we
have the announcement piece right there
uh so you guys know i started locals a
couple years ago i didn't know what the
high hell i was doing i said i said to
jordan peterson
like let's build something together
let's see if we can figure this thing
out let's replace patreon like
everyone's complaining about all of this
stuff this was a few years back uh 2018
and uh jordan then of course obviously
he had some health issues so he stepped
away i kept building locals we got
investors we we built something really
really awesome uh those of you that i
communicate with every day in the local
community you know all about it uh
actually one of my proudest moments in
the last two years is uh it was a little
over a year ago it was december of last
year and we're trying to raise money for
locals before we had merged with rumble
we're trying to raise this money and i
go to this big meeting in miami this
dinner and i'm sitting at a table with
all these investors and we're trying you
know we're selling locals we're trying
to you know raise some funds and i said
you know what guys we keep all talking
about this i'm sitting the table big
table with all these investors i said
we're all talking about this but forget
this i i can sell this thing to you all
day long why don't i just post in my
local community right now hey guys give
me your unfiltered feelings about what
locals is all about and if you're
enjoying this community and all this
stuff and i did it i did not even look
at my phone i said i said i'm gonna now
hand my phone around the table and i
handed my phone around the table and i
said you guys the investors you guys
just look
and you guys who are who are watching on
locals now we got hundreds of responses
and then we got a bunch of investors
that day
it was just a really awesome moment but
anyway in october we merged with rumble
we are building the parallel economy we
are building the parallel pipes of the
internet i i do not believe that twitter
and youtube and instagram and facebook
and the metaverse and all those things
are going to last forever big things
fail and
we are building new and better products
uh so that is absolutely
just awesome and i'm very excited about
that so that was the highlight of
october that we merged and i and it was
really cool you know i didn't
i didn't plan on becoming a tech guy but
i busted my butt uh and the guys in this
room know who who also busted their
butts in the middle of that and helping
me out it was like more of my days were
going to building locals than even doing
the show it was really it was really
crazy and i'm still trying to help
locals in rumble grow and we've got some
major announcements on that front uh
coming in the fall as well uh november
now i had already decided that i was
gonna move this is i have not announced
this i don't think i've ever said what
i'm about to say publicly before by
november we had already mentally i had
decided that i was going to go to
florida but then i went to nashville to
do candace owens show there you there i
am with candace and rob smith and for a
brief moment ladies and gentlemen it is
true
we almost moved to nashville i saw a
house in nashville michael was with me
it was how would you say that house was
beautiful we saw a house i thought about
it i said could i put on the boots could
i put on the cowboy hat could i wear the
little lariat and go and you know hang
out at a honky tonk and eat fried
bologna for breakfast could i live that
life
yeah they eat fried bologna yeah
uh and then i decided not to but it was
we almost moved to nashville that's a
little something so that happened in
november and then in december
once i had already decided what we were
going to do and we had already purchased
the house i finally made the
announcement that we were leaving the
communist dystopian nightmare
of california take a look so i'll give
you the the bumper sticker uh
announcement right now and then i'm to
go into some of my thinking but yes it
is true
i am moving to the great
to the free
and the alligator filled state of
florida yes that's right we have movers
in my house
right now i'm out of here in a couple
days this has been a long time coming uh
i tried my best to save california
california does not want to be saved uh
my entire team connor you still coming
connor's coming i got the thumbs up
michael you're still coming miami mike's
coming my entire team is moving to
florida with me this was no
easy feat but everyone's excited to get
the hell out of here and go to a place
where our talents and skills and
passions will be rewarded
all right first off i have to say
i think florida's been pretty kind i
think i've lost a little weight i feel
good skin looks a little more alive
that's very nice
but yes that was a huge moment that was
a huge moment you know to have my whole
team you know was funny one of the
things that i was worried about like you
don't know when you just make a decision
about your life like are the people
around you are going to be happy with
with you for you
friends family but especially the people
you work with and all of these guys and
and helen and my whole team everybody
was like yes we want out
please take us with you so it was more
of an exodus than anything else and uh
then of course uh we've got video and i
was very very
excited at this moment uh you may
remember this i i had a good friend
who's uh who's got some means and i we
didn't know what we were gonna do with
kai because you know you have to fly
across the country
uh i didn't want to put clyde under the
plane which is what you have to do and
there are you hear these like horrible
stories of dogs that don't make it you
know these cross-country flights so i
contacted a friend who's got a couple
bucks and he lent us his plane it was my
only my second time in a private plane
ever but lent us a plane to escape
communist california me
clyde david david's sister was with us
helping us out and uh here is video
landing in the free state of florida
this was the evening of december
17th 2021 the very moment that we landed
in florida
minerals
[Music]
fantastic
on speed
that was it a day in a moment that i
will never ever ever forget and to my
buddy who hooked us up with the plane
will will always be appreciative of that
but then it started it started to turn
uh i got to florida i could taste
freedom i could feel
that fresh air and see all of the
reptiles
we got settled for a little bit it was
about two three weeks ago getting
settled and of course that was christmas
time as well that's when everyone got
coveted including us uh and then finally
uh in january we did our
first reuben report uh and the good
folks over at newsmax let us use their
studio for a week or two uh here's my
first a little snippet of my first
moment back on the show back in studio
from florida
[Music]
oh that's the good stuff
and if i'm right if all of our hard work
has paid off
if all of the computer machines and the
electronic wires
and all of the weirdo gadgets that these
two fine gentlemen who are in this room
with me right now have been fiddling
with all day if all of that has come
together if that red light that i'm
staring into is working then this is
officially
the first reuben report
from my new house in florida there is an
awful
lot to talk about this is a rare
nighttime show for us but we got the
keys at about noon today it was a mad
dash to get in here it has taken about
two and a half almost three weeks extra
to actually get in here i thought we
were going to get to florida well i know
when we got to florida which was
december 18th i thought maybe we could
close on the house right before
christmas then i thought it could be
right after christmas then it looked
like it was going to be right after new
year that some other stuff happened then
all hell broke loose whole bunch of
things related to covet and delays and
banks and loans and
all these different people pushing paper
across desks
but we made it we are in we've been
busting our butts all day long and this
is my first show from our temporary
florida home studios
all right so we got back in studio
things started to come together life was
feeling good we got into the new house
the team was assembled uh and then and
then kind of life started moving and
settling in and all that uh february was
a really uh interesting month because
something huge did happen in february
you may remember this
when rumble made the 100 million dollar
offer to joe rogan and i think i
mentioned this on the show i was the one
that came up with the idea and i
actually uh i wrote the note and we got
it off to rogan it was a hundred percent
legit uh it was a it was a way that we
could show that you know this of course
was when spotify was a you know everyone
was saying spotify is gonna axe him and
you know joe rogan's a racist because he
said the n-word even though he never
said the n-word to be racist or anything
else but it was just another nice moment
of just like
fighting the good fight and not just
talking about
all of this stuff like getting out there
and doing it so even though rogan didn't
pick us up on that offer maybe he will
in the future and i just thought it was
like let's get out there and fight let's
fight censorship let's fight for free
speech let's fight for an america that
you know was something that was
something that we all remembered that
was pretty good and we kind of handed it
away and it was also that moment i felt
was a good moment in one of the themes
that i talk about all the time here that
this tide was turning and that the
disaffected liberals say the joe rogans
the bill mahers etc that they were
starting to wake up and i felt really
strongly about that and i think over the
last couple months we've seen more and
more of that you know rogan who's now
saying he'll support desantis and and a
whole bunch of other things so march was
an interesting month now we're getting a
little bit more to the news stuff and a
little bit less from the uh to the life
stuff in march because the show was kind
of cooking we're feeling good about
things and then march was was a crazy
month in the news because march was when
uh crazy communist leader
up there in canada justin trudeau
was locking everybody down and then
these canadian truckers this group of
people who really just wanted to live
free and go to work and not be stuck in
their house and not
be just under the endless oppression of
the government when they decided to come
together in a fully grassroots way and
fight the government and i know we have
a huge amount of viewers tremendous
amount of viewers in canada and it's a
large part because i've paid attention
to these issues that have been
completely ignored by the mainstream but
whether it was lockdowns vaccines masks
all of it led to the endless battle that
we all see this this freedom verse
tyranny battle that we're all in in
these last couple of years because of
all the kobit stuff whether we like it
or not the battle is at our it's at our
doorstep right now
and i was very proud to be one of the
people that was leading the fight uh and
defending these truckers and you know
then trudeau was freezing their bank
accounts and a whole bunch more so we
were in that fight bigly as they say in
march this is trudeau talking about the
country that he admires most there's a
level of uh admiration i actually have
for china
because their
basic dictatorship is allowing them
uh to actually turn their economy around
on a diet it's so beautiful when they
tell you exactly what they are and
that's exactly what he did there
i come in with rainbows and unicorns and
tolerance and love and
lgbtqi what are all the other letters
lgdp l gt lbg
and why does he admire china because
china doesn't give a flying f about
their citizens individual rights i sound
like a nice guy but really what i am is
an awful authoritarian
so that's what was going on in march and
again i give i give mad credit as the
kids say i give mad credit to every
single person who in canada stood up
against
their authoritarian government and
justin trudeau who's just a really
really horrible person and he's a stooge
of klaus schwab in the world economic
forum and all of that stuff so i was
glad to be able to amplify some voices
in in that moment that led us to april
and uh something big did happen in april
we launched my second book and went on
tour that's right don't burn this
country came out we did a uh entirely
sold out tour across the country uh with
all sorts of guests there's megan kelly
in west niagara new york that was i
believe that's san jose what a great
theater that's the san jose improv with
douglas murray i'm not even sure i think
that might be chicago if i'm not oh
that's uh that's uh tempe uh no yeah
tempe that's tempe arizona right there
where blake masters and charlie kirk
join me that's dallas where chad prather
joined me glenn beck got laryngitis that
night so he said that glenn beck but the
tour was awesome getting back out there
seeing people again right i mean i had
been seeing people in florida but to do
you know a totally sold out just
amazing energy tour and meeting all you
guys and yes
doing the one second hug which i only
did if people requested that became a
theme people were always like well do i
get the one second hug and it's like
well you got to ask me i can't run
around hugging all you that would be
weird and you know there's a limit to
the amount of hugs there were many
husbands who often would forgo their
hugs so that the wife could get a
two-second hug sometimes wives would
forgo their hug so that the husband
could get a two-second hug which i wish
that was a little bizarre uh but i got
just to meet so many people and and see
the fruits of what we talk about here
that people were kind of all over the
map politically yeah there was like
broadly people sort of thought
themselves as conservatives or something
like that but people weren't obsessed
with gay marriage and they weren't
obsessed with whether you want to smoke
weed in your bedroom at night or just
like that people just really came
together in the name of freedom and they
were disaffected liberals and by the way
there were plenty of religious
conservatives and all of these things
and it was all coming together and i got
to celebrate that for for more than a
month because the tour ended up going
into may and then into june and it was
just absolutely fantastic we'll get to
more of that in just a moment in may the
big thing was that uh because i
mentioned a moment ago you know these
these disaffected liberals these rogan
bill maher types who are kind of coming
around and slow but they that they're
for the average i don't like the phrase
average but for the
for the person out there uh who's
waiting for someone else to give a
signal the signals have started to come
so the big thing in may
was that elon musk said that no he's not
a democrat anymore he's been a democrat
his whole life but he was going to do it
he was going to vote for those scary
republicans
um you know the the the reality is uh
that that twitter at this point you know
has uh a very far-left bias um and i i
would class myself as a moderate and you
know neither the republican nor democrat
um and in fact uh i have voted vote
overwhelmingly for democrats uh
historically overwhelmingly like i'm not
sure
i might never have voted for a
republican just to be clear right now
now this election i would
pretty good moment pretty good moment
then of course then elon elon got into
the the battle with twitter whether he
was going to buy it or not buy it he at
the very least at this point has exposed
twitter to be complete nonsense and i do
have to say out of all of the the social
media platforms that i'm about to take a
break from twitter is the one that kind
of sits there in my head like of all of
them is am i going to actually go back
to twitter i guess we shall see
um jordan peterson obviously after he
got banned for his tweet about ellen
page who or i guess elliott page who
used to be ellen page who was in x-men
which is kind of funny uh
is not on there anymore maybe that is
the route that most sane people should
be going but at the very least whether
elon gets it and defends free speech or
not he has exposed it to be a total
cesspool of sensorious insanity so i
think that that's great so that's what
happened in may and it's just like
another win like good things we're
building throughout the year then in
june uh we finished up the don't burn
this country tour and we finished it up
in mickey mouse's hometown of orlando
florida with the man who smacked down
the mouse yes of course
you all know the governor of the free
state of florida ron desantis uh he got
into a fight with disney because disney
decided that they wanted to brainwash
all of your children and have your boys
be girls and your girls be boys and then
of course the state
and actually the federal government they
have been teaching all these kids this
gender nonsense and they do it privately
without anyone knowing it has nothing to
do with gay or straight or any of those
things you guys know all that
so i did our last show uh of the tour in
orlando with governor desantis and i
thought could i say gay to the ron
desantis what what might happen
all right so
first off we have to start with the
obvious one
gay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he didn't even flinch
[Music]
nothing and it was really just a
fantastic moment you know a bunch of
protesters show up and they disturb the
show and all of that stuff but it was
just a perfect culmination
of the tour it really like storybook for
me couldn't have been better that the
governor of the state that i came to
that i'm now fighting for that i think
is the tip of the spear of freedom and
if america is going to continue in the
western world is continue it's all right
here and to to finish the tour with him
was absolutely fantastic and then as uh
as some of you know and some of you have
seen we then took my uh 40 or 45 minute
uh stand up that i did before we brought
ron desantis on stage and i released my
first ever stand-up special which annual
subscribers on locals get absolutely
free which by the way in case you forgot
little radio reset for you if you go to
reubenreport.com
support today only this is the best deal
of the year it's the only day we're
doing this you get three months free off
an annual membership and you get the
special free and a whole bunch more uh
here's a little uh promo of the stand-up
special
ladies and gentlemen please welcome host
of the reuben report author of don't
burn this country and new floridian dave
rubin
so they're out there and if you saw
these people they're they're chanting
they're literally chanting we
say gay
at my show
i don't just say it i mean i'm doing it
you know what i mean
disney has lost 41
billion dollars
donald duck
is wandering the streets of orlando
sucking dick for a hot lunch
how many of you are conservatives
okay conservatives that basically means
you have a job
so
good for you guys thank you very very
mean and very scary
ben shapiro is four foot six okay
he's actually in my pocket right now
you guys want to see him
[Applause]
all right so that was june it was just a
great way to end the month and uh and
end the tour it was just absolutely
fantastic and then july rolled around
and then in july uh and we're at the end
of july right now i think the big thing
for this month is i did an interview
with jordan peterson and jordan peterson
of course uh has just announced that he
is moving over to the daily wire
and he asked me to do the first
interview on his show so for the first
time him interviewing me i've
interviewed him you know
well if you had the tour and i've
interviewed him hundreds of times
but you know on camera i've interviewed
him probably a dozen times or so but we
flipped the script and jordan felt that
it was it was important and vital that
we have a conversation
around a gay couple having kids and the
importance of family and all those
things and how he influenced me all
along the way uh and i was honored and
thrilled to be jordan's first guest on
his daily wire show and actually if you
haven't seen it much of it's on his
youtube channel but you can get it on
the daily wire it probably was the most
important public conversation i've ever
had certainly the most personal and we
we went deep and we knew we left a lot
on the table too
so we probably will pick it up but
here's just a little piece of my chat
with jordan peterson if you would have
said to me 10 years ago that i'd be
having this conversation publicly first
off that i knew that i'd be married i
wouldn't have believed you that i'd have
be having kids i wouldn't have believed
you that i would be willing to talk
about this or even someone that even
someone that someone else might look to
to help map it for them i'd say you were
completely insane um this is not really
something you know i'd rather talk about
politics i'd rather talk about the
culture wars and all of these other
things this is the political party
because we're trying to sketch out a
pathway i suppose i mean our culture
appears to have decided that
gay marriage is
well i don't know if acceptable is the
right word it's become part of the
structure of marriage itself and so now
the question is
okay what does that mean
we went deep we talked about things that
are not
talked about
that we talked about the stuff that's
tough related to all of this and that
you can have sort of the standard and
what are the things that you can have
roughly approximate to that and how does
a family
uh grow if it's different than say the
norm and we all grow up in families that
are probably different than the norm and
the ideal and all of those things
meaning there are plenty of straight
families who have you know a parent that
abandons the kids or is an alcoholic or
the parents are emotionally unavailable
and all of those things and then you
have same-sex couples and it's just
different it's just different people
think that automatically means it's
worse it doesn't it doesn't you could
have same-sex parents that are really
fantastic and give that kid all that
love and all that stuff and safety and
security and and thoughtfulness and and
set them out on the world in a great way
and you can have that from a straight
couple or a gay couple
so we just dived into absolutely all
that and it's just the beginning we're
going to pick it up you know on the
other side of parenthood for me so that
that was july and then of course these
you know these last couple weeks where
we've been just sort of getting ready
for this this this off the grid moment
so we have a gillion
questions from the reuben report
community and then i've got my 10
craziest moments of the year like the 10
craziest clips or sort of most
meaningful or silly or ridiculous clips
that we could find uh real quick though
guys i gotta remind you if you have not
bought them yet you gotta get the blaze
socks they've got all of these limited
release limited edition socks you can go
to blazesocks.com
use co promo code ruben socks you can
get the big d energy i really thought
that was me at first when they uh when
they sent this sent this to us but it's
ron desantis
and he's owning the libs of course and
you've got klaus schwab and you've got
joe biden riding
his convertible into hell and all that
good stuff uh if you are a blaze
subscriber you're going to get an extra
20 off uh and the rest you can go to
blaze
socks.com use promo code ruben socks put
on some blaze socks feel good about life
oh and by the way just one more little
clerical thing if you do
the the sign up over at uh
reubenreport.com support not only do you
get three months off the annual today
only but we're gonna send out as many of
these reuben report
shirts as possible we're moving stock
today we got to make room for milk and
diapers
and other such stuff for the kids so
that's what we're going to do all right
let's jump into the reuben report
community q a and you guys can keep
throwing in questions they'll throw them
on the fly to me and then as i said
we'll get back to the
to the top ten moments and all that good
stuff uh mark says dave upon your return
what are a couple of things that you
hope to hear and a couple of things
absolutely hope not to hear
well
hope to hear i mean it would be nice if
things got saner but there's almost no
way to map that right like it would be
nice if perhaps the biden administration
you know maybe was like actually we're
not gonna be raising taxes right now
we're not going to be endlessly printing
money i mean joe biden gave a speech
yesterday it was after we did our live
stream that was absolutely
terrible i mean they basically want to
raise taxes on corporations keep
printing money and the same people who
wreck the economy they just think that
they still have all the answers and of
course we know they're redefining the
word
recession right now i mean literally
doing it in real time wikipedia the the
the definition of the word recession on
wikipedia was edited 38 times yesterday
in the official wikipedia entry so it's
just it's just all endless propaganda
everywhere so the thing i would love to
come back to is like some sense of
normalcy or
like a little sort of reversal of how
things have been but like i can't even
imagine how that could be at a national
level i can believe it at a federal
level i have a feeling i'll come back to
florida that will be even stronger right
ron desantis will be about a month and a
half out from crushing his re-election
and continuing all the good work that
he's done here so i'll feel good about
that i think but it's hard to figure out
like what could be good that has
anything to do with the culture war or
the or the political war
that would sort of reverse and things
would be good i don't know which is why
i believe in in the local thing as for
things i i really wouldn't want to come
back to i mean i
i don't even want to say this but i do
think i think it is literally 50 50 that
joe biden will even be president by the
time i come back i think the way he has
broken down
we showed you that video yesterday where
they have him so hopped up on these
drugs and he can't blink anymore and
covet and he can't remember anything and
all that stuff like
i would never want to come back to that
because first off i would like the
president to be functional but then we
got president kamala harris and then
they're going to figure out how to move
pelosi out and bring new something in
like
i don't know i don't even want to think
about it but but that's a weird thing
like never in all the years that i've
done the off the grid thing was i like
ah there's a pretty good chance the
president won't be the president when i
get back you know we last year for
example i i didn't uh i missed the
afghanistan withdrawal which was a
disaster i didn't know it was going to
happen and it was a disaster enough the
year before i missed that kamala harris
was announced the vp john mccain died
like every year there's some stuff
andrew cuomo was pushed out last august
you know there's always some stuff but
this year it's full on like i don't know
that the president will be the president
that that's a weird one and it will be
kind of interesting to see you know i'm
really we're going to hunker down here
at home and obviously we'll have family
with us
around birth and all that stuff but like
if the president's gone like will is if
i wander into whole foods am i gonna
hear it like are people going to be
screaming or freaking out or happy or
who knows we shall see
kelly says i know this will be your most
memorable time off the grid ever will
you please send out some smoke signals
out to your reuben family when the
little bundle arrives yes this is going
to be the only thing we're going to do
i'm not going to do it myself because i
won't have my phone or my computer or
ipad or anything but yes we will post at
least one picture of uh happy
parents and a hopefully happy healthy
baby on uh on the day that he is born um
oh i thought for a second i was giving
away the sex but we've already announced
that and ultimately we'll get the we'll
let the kid decide uh but uh yeah we
will do that that will be only for local
subscribers nobody else not posting it
across anything else and all that good
stuff and yes this is going to obviously
be the most memorable of all of them
although if you've never sat
on an over the water bungalow in bora
bora with your feet up having a little
cappuccino in the morning
could having a kid be better than that
honestly
maybe all right
christian says would you mind sharing
some bits of advice you received from
jordan and dennis also you will surely
be missed i can't even imagine what the
world will look like a month from now so
what you're referring to there i only
posted this in the locals community i
had jordan peterson and dennis prager
over for dinner just the three of us the
other night um and i felt
like you know this is i'm running out of
days before i'm a parent and it's like
who would i rather sit down than than
these two guys who have just so affected
me uh and help me evolve and change and
be a better person and stand up straight
with my shoulders back and
put truth into the world and put some
order into the world and all of those
things so uh we had a great dinner we
had steak as you can imagine and uh i
did actually then david joined us and
then a little later uh tammy jordan's
wife joined us as well uh dennis's wife
sue uh was back in cali um and uh we
sort of had them go around the table and
and kind of give us a little bit advice
so some some of it was kind of clerical
uh
you know tammy gave us some stuff like
like serious like functional stuff about
you know holding the baby and
skin-to-skin contact and little things
like that jordan's advice you know was
was very jordan peterson to be honest it
was uh
it was very you know set guardrails for
these kids set walls that they know they
can't punch through and they will
respect you for that and and it was a
lot of that sort of stuff you know
dennis dennis has affected me in a
different way because i think and i said
this to jordan and dennis you know
jordan has affected me in the
in the sort of like get your [ __ ]
together get your [ __ ] together because
if you're going to bring a child into
this world you may as well have your
[ __ ] together otherwise you're going to
hand a whole bunch of [ __ ] to this kid
right so jordan has really helped me on
that front right and that's actually
regardless of whether you have a kid or
not like that's jordan's main message
get your [ __ ] together get your [ __ ]
together and if you do that i don't know
maybe something good will happen right
that's jordan dennis for me and dennis
and i have become extremely close and
dennis sort of feels like a like a uncle
or something to me um dennis has really
reconnected me with a lot of the
tradition and knowledge of my past you
know dennis got me going back to temple
dennis holds these high holiday services
which he does in los angeles but i'm
trying to get dennis to florida we shall
see if i can get dennis in the whole
prageru operation to move here but
dennis really connected me with that
connected me with the family thing again
the tradition thing again um and he's
just they're just great i mean i talk
about privilege people always talk about
privilege like i'm privileged to know
people that everyone want
to meet
and be part of their lives and uh that
is that is pretty
fantastic uh robin says what are you
looking forward to doing the most during
your off the grid month um
well one thing i'll give you one thing
uh we have been doing a lot of
construction around the house and i am
told
that today
it's completed which worked out nicely
now they've been telling me that for
months this is how things work in joe
biden's economy because you can't get a
screw you can't get a window you can't
get drywall and everything's crazy
expensive but they are finally telling
me everything will be done today so what
i would like to do tonight
is smoke
a giant rib eye
and you know what i'm going to feed you
guys
you guys want to eat dinner all right
dinner it is for this be this group of
people um you know what am i looking
forward to the most honestly like the
next couple days it's just like you know
we're hoping
technically the the due date for for the
baby is august 22nd
our gut feeling is it's going to be
around the 15th so i think we have about
two weeks of like just a little detached
like get you know the house in order
sort of stuff um i don't know just lay
in the pool a little bit
i got a couple books i want to read but
like
we're not going to go anywhere we're
just going to hunker down i'll probably
uh you know one of the things that
happens in august in almost every august
i basically never put hairspray in my
hair usually wear a hat or a bandana i
pretty much don't shave
days go by i can tell you this where i
don't shower
i jump in the pool it's a salt water
pool it's very clean you come out
feeling clean don't shower for days
rarely put shoes on i got my my
flip-flops or what are they not
flip-flops would i have my sliders got
the sliders and i'm out there and and
it's always funny because when people
see me if i'm at a store i'm at home
depot or something people are like come
on dave come on dave you have your phone
on you i know you're not off the grid
and i'm literally like at the store like
pulling out my pockets i got nothing man
um so i'm looking forward to i guess
i'll i'll fully be florida man by the
end of this thing like i'm just gonna be
like overly tanned big ass beard like
look like i just got out of the jungle
and then and then baby uh nick says uh
basketball may require five players for
each team but since you and candace
owens will each have two kids after this
year oh and congratulations to candace
and george candace just had her second
baby uh louise just about a week ago
will you be planning a farmer
versus ruben family scrimmage match for
whenever they are old enough to play i
would like to do that
david and i have discussed it's like you
know i want these kids to play
basketball he wants these kids to play
golf
he's a good golfer i'm a good basketball
player can they play both what if they
want soccer which neither one of us like
what do we do with that you can't give
the kid away at that point can you you
can't from what i'm told
what if they like hockey i don't like
hockey at all so we have to figure that
out you know george of course is
candace's husband george he's british
they may want cricket
but we will figure out something that
that will work uh kathy says if you came
back from your month off the grid and
found out that joe biden was dead would
you be surprised i mean no
how sad like how ridiculous and sad
that is like i take no pleasure in that
absolutely no pleasure in that and by
the way when i say that it's 50 50 that
he may not be president when i come back
i mean it's not that i think he
necessarily will die
but i think it's very possible that he
will have a breakdown to the extent that
the hiding of this nonsense the
conspiracy
that
is the conspiracy that nobody talks
about that's the real conspiracy right
it's not the conspiracy that they're
hiding it's a conspiracy that everyone
hides it on top of the people who are
inside that are hiding it right um
it may break down to the point that they
won't be able to hide it anymore right
it will just burst forth and be so
obvious that they'll just have to take
him out
again my feelings on this
are that they want him to get through
the midterms because then it'll be a
disaster they'll all pin the blame on
him and then they get rid of him after
the midterms but i just think the truth
is relative to the health it's like it
could just happen at any moment it's
just how it is
happy chef will you be taking another
trip to bora bora then you can catch up
on your rest before you become a data
e-ticket ride dave may the force be with
you both in this next great adventure
god bless yeah we can't do that we can't
do the big trip
surrogate is here uh had her and her
kids over yesterday for pizza and a
little pool time
and we can't we can't go because we got
to be there and be in the hospital and
be ready all hands on deck it could
literally happen at any moment so there
will be no bora bora there will be no
rainforest this is it this is what
happens guys you know you guys aren't
married yet you don't have kids yet
enjoy it guys
you know are you
you hearing me you got to enjoy it go to
bora bora get out of here
uh a 60 dude says all right dave it's
that time again do you have any
predictions on major stories or updates
what will happen while you're off the
grid um
what will happen well look
the meltdown of the democrats and and
the exposure of the nonsense
will continue
there is just no way these people can
reverse this thing
the inmates are running the asylum the
incompetent buffoons from top down from
from biden to kamala harris to janet
yellen to jean corinne pierre to all of
the deputies and managers and all just
the entire party has just been rotted
out and that happens to be the party
that's in charge at the federal level
right now none of that is going to
reverse so i i suspect just more
nonsense like just more nonsense but
it's like what could happen i don't know
could could the ukraine war it's like is
that happening anymore are we funding it
anymore are we in war could that go hot
again could they bring back kovid
could uh monkey pox go bananas or could
they just make you you think that monk
epoxy's going bananas oh and guys i just
want to reiterate when i'm gone for
august no orgies just no anonymous
orgies all right
it's one thing i ask we don't cover that
on the reuben report health insurance
okay uh yeah don't have orgies with a
bunch of people you don't know if you'd
like to avoid monkey pox that's my
advice for you on that right but it's
like anything
that's really what i feel right now like
in a in a newer way
or i guess in a more specific way than
in years past it's like there is almost
no what could i possibly come back to
that it would be like
oh that happened aren't you shocked
you know like anything the monkeys could
take over the world right we could be
living in planet of the apes and i'd be
like all right what are you gonna do you
know we have a banana tree back there so
we'd be okay uh big poppy says do you
worry that you may have a woke doctor
delivering the babies and they will put
tbd on the birth certificate that's
money no i've met the doctor he is he is
a great ob gyn we've met him he's a
really good dude nice guy like very warm
and pleasant i have no uh indication
that there is going to be a problem with
him misgendering the child or anything
like that um
so i think we're going to be okay i
don't think he knew who i was which i
was sort of relieved in a way
but yeah i think we're going to be good
on that front uh eamonn says what's an
insult you receive that you're proud
of well you know people will say um
something it'll be like oh you've sold
out to the right
like you've sold out to the right which
i always think is so hilarious first off
i've done this show over the years like
i've always gone more and more
independent i've taken a million risks
to keep building this thing you know i
left the young turks when we had
basically nothing and i left our jobs in
our health insurance and then we left
aura tv and we went independent and we
literally had nothing and that night
before we launched our patreon i had no
idea if i was even going to be able to
live literally we had like 2 000 bucks
in our bank account
like and i took my team with me and it
worked
we've always made the moves that i just
thought were right i've gone in the
direction that i thought was right
politically that i've gone in the right
direction
well no i'd say it this way i went in
the right direction that i thought was
political and then through that
opportunity presented itself and then
through that i also made decisions to to
get
more into the game say by creating
locals that kind of thing so
um so yeah you want to call me a sellout
like yes i moved to la to become
non-woke and fight the entire machine
and campaign with the black face of
white supremacy and you know be around
conservatives who are supposed to hate
gay people and all of those things it's
like you know that's another funny one
you know these people i'll see these
tolerant you know these very tolerant
lefties and they'll be like dave see the
conservatives hate you and it's like oh
yeah they hate me that my book is a
best-selling book we have all these
people that watch the show i tore all of
these things and it's like the people
who hate me are always telling me that
the people who like me hate me
it's a very weird thing very weird thing
cheryl says you say you love seinfeld
which episode is your favorite
that's a tough one i would say they it
definitely involves either george's
parents the costanzas or jerry's parents
obviously the seinfeld marble ride might
be it that dinner that george's parents
have with susan's parents when they're
sitting there
is one of the funniest absolute funniest
things and george's father about you got
the chicken and you got the hen then
who's doing it and the whole thing's
perverse it's just like absolutely
perfect but i can pretty much watch any
epis i mean soup nazi is fantastic like
even the end you know a lot of people
hated the end of seinfeld two-part
episode where they all get arrested for
not helping the fat guy and then they
all go on trial and they bring back all
the old characters and uh larry david
who had left the show for the last two
seasons he came back and and did it a
lot of people did not like it i loved it
i thought it was a great great ending to
the to the show uh keep in mind guys we
are gonna do our top 10 moments of the
year when we do it we'll do a few more
questions maybe we'll jump from
questions we'll do the top ten come back
to some questions why don't we do that
so i'll do one more question now we'll
do some top ten and then we'll go from
there lauren says dave did you always
want to be a stand-up or talk show host
or did you have any desire to be a
fireman or a baseball player when you
were growing up do you have a preference
oops do you have a preference to what
you want your boys to do when they're
older well
first off i always wanted to be a
basketball player
but alas it never came to fruition um
but um you know it i guess it was meant
to be that all of this was meant to be a
couple years ago i went into my high
school yearbook and everyone in my high
school yearbook everyone wrote you're
gonna host the tonight show one day
that's what everybody wrote i don't even
remember that from back then but like my
friends were all funny
um i did a little radio show at my high
school at the time um but it was it was
actually about basketball but everyone
said you're gonna host the tonight show
you're gonna you're gonna be the next
johnny carson and that kind of thing um
so i didn't end up hosting tonight nor
would i want to host the tonight show
but i did become a talk show host i
suppose and uh and the stand-up thing
came around and and somehow it all sort
of worked as for what i want my kids to
do
i mean i hope something that that gives
them some sense of meaning that helps
them build a life that they think is
worthy of living and uh sets them up i
suppose in some way that's roughly
approximate to how i've been set up here
all right so we'll get to some more
questions later why don't we do this
this top 10 these are the top 10
craziest moments these are media moments
they are political moments these are
clips we have shown you throughout the
year we went through a whole i mean i
assure you to whittle it down to just 10
with some of the idiocy that is on msnbc
in the view and uh a whole bunch more um
it was not easy uh but uh here we go so
we're gonna do the top ten moments
you're gonna remember some of these some
of them you may have forgotten some of
them you may wish you forgot here is
number 10.
in massachusetts
right now
those
crisis pregnancy centers
that are there
to fool people who are looking for
pregnancy termination help
outnumber true abortion clinics by three
to one
we need to shut them down here in
massachusetts and we need to shut them
down all around the country
you should not be able
to torture a pregnant person like that
man i know you guys remember that one
because we played it a couple of times
and it was only a couple weeks ago and
you should not be able to torture a
pregnant person like that you shouldn't
be able to torture pregnant person
that's what we call a woman right and
having a baby usually most women uh say
that's the biggest blessing in their
lives that this is the most wonderful
thing they could possibly do and what
that woman wants elizabeth warren that
crazy communist who is worth millions
and millions of dollars who sends her
kids to private school while she's
against vouchers and all of those things
what she wants is dead babies she wants
a lot of dead babies and a lot of dead
brown and black babies actually
she's a bad bad woman i don't like her
very much
and hopefully that and that's the last
time i have to think about elizabeth
warren for the summer here
is number nine
50 000 ukrainians will be dead or
wounded and that this is going to start
a humanitarian crisis a refugee crisis
in europe we're talking about five
million people
that that are going to be displaced i
mean
it's it's heartbreaking to hear what is
going to happen yeah well i'm scared of
what's going to happen in in western
europe too yeah you know you just you
plan a trip you want to go there i want
to go to italy for four years i haven't
been able to make it because of
of uh the pandemic and now this you know
it's like who's gonna what's gonna
happen there
yeah
i mean of all of the clips of the
insanity on the view right like this was
a nutty week for the view this week with
joy behar and whoopi pretending that
there were nazis at the turning point
event whoopi basically denying the
holocaust that it had anything to do
with race like of all of the insane
things that they have said on the view
that one really holds a special place
that they're talking about the war in
ukraine and the five million refugees
and the lives lost and all of the stuff
and joy can't go to italy
where is joy behar gonna get her
mushroom risotto she'll have to keep
getting it on the upper west side of
manhattan that poor woman i mean really
just the the myopic
self-absorbed
insanity of the modern liberal is so
perfectly encapsulated by the once
saying
joy behar
here's number eight
my mother drove us and rather than us
able to walk
and guess what
the first frost you know what was
happening
it had to put on your windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why i and so damn many other
people i grew up have cancer
and why can't for the longest time
delaware had the highest cancer rate in
the nation
so that was about two weeks ago is the
president of the united states
announcing that he has cancer having
something to do with an oil slick way
back when and uh the reason i thought
that one was funny is because for only
five minutes did people care that the
president of the united states said he
had cancer because pretty much everyone
said no no no it's not that he has
cancer it's that he has dementia so
let's just let it slide
the white house issued a statement
saying that it was actually just he
screwed up the tents he had cancer
meaning he's had some things removed he
does not have cancer but it was just
like a perfect example of the nonsense
from this administration this guy who
can't do these anecdotes right anymore
who can't read these things right
anymore he thinks he has cancer he
doesn't know where he is you know it's
just absolute insanity with this guy and
again will he be president when i get
back i suppose we'll find out
here's number seven
president biden he is saying he's going
to run again in 2024 will you support
him
yeah you know i think we should
endorse when we get to it but i i
believe that the president has been
doing a very good job uh so far and um
you know should he run again i think
that
i you know i think it's it's
we'll take a look at it
but right now we need to focus on
winning a majority instead of a
presidential election so the reason we
wanted to throw that one in and you know
i take no great pleasure in showing you
aoc videos and trust me there's a
million things we could have shown you
of her doing something stupid is there
was something bizarrely refreshing about
aoc going on cnn and basically being
like no we're done with biden and that's
why she's laughing as she says it
because she knows it but she knows she
can't fully say it yet but there was
something kind of honest and refreshing
about that and the other thing is that
that was an interesting moment because
that was about a month ago now and that
was right when suddenly if you remember
before that nobody in mainstream media
was talking about what's wrong with
biden right nobody was saying it yes
here we're saying it online shows
they're saying it rogan's saying it
shapiro's saying it you know you're
probably saying it in your in your own
circles
but aoc did that and then it was one of
those airlock moments you know how we
have these weird airlock moments where
we all know something's true but for
some reason it can't get through
mainstream media oh could there be a
wuhan lab leak everyone's talking about
it online for two years then finally jon
stewart goes on colbert he says it and
then everyone can start talking about it
right hunter biden laptop we're all
talking about online but nobody's saying
anything then finally new york times two
years later says something now
everybody's talking about it that was
sort of an airlock moment aoc we're all
talking about something's not right we
buy it and aoc goes there laughs about
it
boom now everyone's basically saying the
democrats are done with him and his time
is up so he's dead man walking and i
just thought that was an interesting
sort of seminal moment
number six
it's independence day so let's talk
about what's going on in america freedom
is under attack in your state republican
leaders they're banning books making it
harder to vote restricting speech in
classrooms even criminalizing women and
doctors i urge all of you living in
florida to join the fight or join us in
california but we still believe in
freedom freedom of speech freedom to
choose freedom from hate and the freedom
to love don't let them take your freedom
paid for by news and for california
governor 2020.
the blood could boil even though i don't
live under that guy anymore i mean
really the most evil person in american
politics today
and that's why he's the perfect democrat
and that's why he probably will be the
nominee after biden because that's how
this thing operates that the fact that
that swarmy slimy soulless
vapid nothing that he dares even say the
word freedom
uh is is so vile he hates freedom uh all
you guys know all the stuff that he's
done and all the lockdowns and the
destruction of california and that about
300 000 people have fled california and
they've come here nobody we couldn't
find it we scoured the internet could we
find one nut bag who moved from florida
to california in all of these last years
we couldn't find any u-haul can't get
trucks to go back that way they go this
way so u-haul is hurting he's the number
one u-haul salesman the guy is just
absolutely the worst he lie every single
thing he said in that video was a lie
that they're coming for freedoms and
they're banning books in florida
nonsense actually in cali they're
banning books because of words they
banned to kill a mockingbird in some
california schools because of certain
words they don't like they're not coming
for gays in florida he's just
absolutely awful you get it
number five
the diversity of this community
as distinct as the bogotas of the bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in san antonio
is your strength
of course that was a couple weeks ago dr
jill biden who you always have to
mention she's a doctor otherwise you're
racist uh and dr jill of course who
clearly has not uh examined her husband
uh she's also not that kind of doctor
but let's put that aside uh just the
endless pandering
the reason that that video went viral
because it was just the perfect example
of the endless pandering that the
democrats do much like hillary clinton
what does she do she keeps hot sauce in
her purse right remember that she keeps
hot sauce in her purse when she's
talking to black people because black
people must like spicy food something
like that these people are just terrible
and they're and they're getting hit with
it at the end like it's finally coming
around where every time they do one of
their
their pandering moments joe biden you
know trump's gonna put you back in
chains and they use their fake accents
when they're with these people and all
of these things it's like people are
seeing it they're so seeing right
through it it's just spectacular am i am
i under assault right now is the
internet coming for me
these are not sponsors of the show i
don't know what those things are
number four
uh can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
is so unclear and controversial that you
can't give me
a definition
what a moment i mean that that in some
ways we could have put that as number
one but i think you're gonna dig the
number one but that moment when katanji
brown jackson who is now a supreme court
justice could not say what a woman is
and people kept saying oh it doesn't
matter it was a loaded question
and it's like well actually look at all
the gender stuff that has even exploded
even more in the say two months since
then right now and and when you don't
know what a woman is then you don't know
what a recession is and you don't know
what basic math is these people do not
want us to know anything that we do know
that we have always accepted as true and
that in some ways is the most seminal
moment of the year you know speaking of
our background freaking out a second ago
i should tell you guys one of our little
surprises for you when we get back in
september we're gonna have an all new
background
you guys are gonna be doing work i'm
gonna be
laying at the pool but you guys will be
busting your asses working in august
here's number three
there was no mental health issue with
the individual who stole the futures of
19 children in uvalde texas
all the crazy things that that woman has
ever said
joy reid and joy reid is a racist and a
buffoon and just
total clown and all that stuff and
there's all these rumors that msnbc's
going to get rid of her but the the
knee-jerk defense uh by the mainstream
media and by people like her to say
that this is only about guns that these
shootings are only about guns i mean her
implication right there i mean really if
you really think about it the
implication this young man goes into
this school he shoots 19 people i think
it ended up being 17 kids and two
teachers if i'm not mistaken he had no
mental health issues
by definition if you do that you have
severe mental health issues i cannot
imagine there is a psychologist
or a psychiatrist on earth
that would say if you shoot all of these
people unjustly you murder in cold blood
all of these children you have no mental
health issues it's it's that is insane
she has mental health issues truly i
truly believe that that is a woman with
serious mental health issues but because
they believe in narrative over reality
right they believe in narrative over
fact she needs to throw out that because
what does she want to happen when when
someone gets shot it's immediately well
how can we do this to infringe on other
people's rights how can we come for guns
what can we do politically
to have more power over people
but again in the theme of today and
these throwback clips it's like more and
more people are seeing it more and more
people are seeing that gavin newsom's a
liar that elizabeth warren wants to
murder babies that these people have no
basic understanding of our rights or
anything else and here is number two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
man
i mean sad right like it's sad again
like i'm not a biden guy i don't like
what this guy's done to the country i
don't think he knows what he's doing or
where he is half the time but that
disrespect
that shade thrown by obama who i regret
voting for twice i really regret i think
barack obama has turned out to be an
absolutely uh terrible uh
terrible person he's just he's just
everything that i'm pushing against
right um the smugness like he knows they
don't just let people touch him right
people aren't just allowed to touch him
he knew that the president's hand was on
his shoulder there and he didn't care
that [ __ ] eating grin
while he's ignoring the president and
kamala ignoring the president abiding
not knowing where to go or who to talk
to and it's like who's in charge right
we always say who's really in charge and
maybe we got a little glimpse of it
right there as to who really is in
charge because who seemed more in
control of that room right there who
were people excited to see right there
was it joe biden hey where am i someone
talk to me brock brock or was it the guy
[ __ ] eating grin i mean that's the
definition of [ __ ] eating grin as he is
ignoring the president of the united
states and this one so you may ask well
that joy read one that i showed you
before
some of these any any of these could
have been number one but this is the one
that clearly is number one and you will
understand why
it's just such an unbelievable
moment
brandon you also told me
as you can hear the chance from the the
crowd
let's go brandon brandon you told me you
were gonna kind of hang back those first
two stages and just watch and learn what
did you learn that helped you there in
those closing laps oh my god it was uh
learning how each line didn't uh
stay to one it everything shifted top to
bottom so much that it was kind of like
okay let's just stay patient where we're
at and hope it's just so perfect so in
case you forgot that was back in
september right and that was the moment
that that kid brandon nascar driver
brandon
he's being interviewed and everyone in
the crowd is chanting [ __ ] joe biden
that's what they're saying but the media
runs cover so instead she took [ __ ] joe
biden and she turned it into let's go
brandon and it became a meme and it's on
t-shirts and everything else uh by the
way we're gonna give away a couple of
these too today for people that sign up
if you go to reubenreport.com support
you will get three months off an annual
subscription and we're just gonna send
out a whole bunch of shirts and a whole
bunch of reuben report shirts uh and
much more but that really is the moment
of the year that really is the moment of
the year because that meme
it captured a feeling it captured what
we were all trying to say but couldn't
quite figure out how to say it maybe a
little whatever and and it was funny and
irreverent and then of course the media
started running all these stories that
people who say let's go brand that are
white supremacists and all the stuff
but also having the media cover for him
it was that to me is the moment of the
year so since last september uh to right
now that really really was the moment of
the year oh i should remember uh or
remind you guys rather that uh this
afternoon five o'clock am i right five
o'clock think we're doing at five
o'clock
at five o'clock uh i'm going to be
having drinks with the locals community
so we're going to be doing a separate
live stream this will be my official off
the grid goodbye that's it and and we'll
get we'll get real personal we're going
to i'm going to drink some tequila you
could drink your drink of choice and
that will be a local's exclusive live
stream again it's
reubenreport.locals.com
uh let's get to a couple more questions
and uh and then we'll see what else we i
think we got a couple announcements and
then uh
we'll move on with our lives
sweetwater says how does david feel
about the move since he's left cali to
florida you know it took him a little
while i got here and i was like
balls to the wall like i love the place
i love the lizards and the peacocks and
the humidity and everything and you know
i'm getting invited to all these things
with the governor and
the mayor and i'm just like loving it
from the second we got here it took him
a little while longer because he had to
deal with some more of the nitty-gritty
of our life uh we had a lot of work that
we had to do at the house as i've told
you uh we had to get you know things our
staff in order and like all of that kind
of stuff i think he also in california
you know despite
the insanity of california we had a good
life in california we had we had good
friends we we had a good thing going we
had we had a beautiful home and we
really had stuff that was good and and
we had put something together that was
cohesive and
felt right uh man because he doesn't
care about politics the way that i do
i'd be it'd be the end of the day you
know we'd be like in the pool and i'd be
just going on and on about lockdowns and
masks and these and i hate this guy and
gavin newsom and bubba and he'd be like
uh you know what do you want for dinner
you know like he just doesn't care about
that stuff that much so i was more
frustrated so i was definitely the one
that kind of pushed it more um but as he
has said to me i'm very happy to say
that as he has said to me many times
over the last couple weeks he really is
happy here he's very excited now about
the kids and the life that we've built
here and we've done a lot to the house
so it feels like ours now
and uh yeah it took it took a little
while you know because if you're if
you're in the thick of it if you're in
the thick of it you feel things that
other people who are just kind of going
about their lives don't necessarily feel
i think that's kind of why we why we
work we have sort of different
our sort of basic outlook of the world
is the same but our sort of granular
stuff is a little bit different i think
that's kind of what you want when you
when you find somebody to do the life
thing with why not huh
cobalt says have you used your pool or
enjoyed the beach it's hot enough to
enjoy the water each day so yes we get
in the pool one way or another i try
even if it's just at the end of the day
literally to just jump in for a second
but i will tell you this miami pool
summer uh that pool our pool is
literally well you guys are in we go
have you ever been in a hot or pool
like i kid you not we don't heat this
thing we do not heat this thing it's
about 95 degrees because it's hot every
day here obviously and you know this is
interesting i didn't know this because
of the humidity if you think about it it
makes a lot of sense because of the
humidity especially in in florida in the
summer the water the air is so dense
with water right that humid air that the
water is not evaporating so your pool
which is basically you know being beaten
down with sun all day long and now it's
not evaporating the way it normally
would it's just warming up and warming
up and warming up so if it's
like 92 degrees outside and i jump in a
95 degree it's hot like i get in there
and i'm like cooking sometimes so you
can legit sweat in the pool
i'm not complaining though i love
florida
i'm never leaving they are going to bury
me in the everglades like that's it for
me
and we haven't been to the beach too
much actually we've just been so busy
but actually one thing we've discussed
is if we have a little time before the
babies now we're trying to do some beach
stuff uh next week
tony says if you could remake or reboot
one movie what would it be oh man that's
a good one
my easy answer is you know if there was
any chance but i just don't have a
chance you know any chance anymore with
disney and everything else it's like
star wars needs to be blown apart from
the beginning and just completely
rethought at every freaking level and
you take some of the lore and you just
redo absolutely everything but disney's
got it i'm kind of done with star wars
it's it's sad for me
maybe that's a little facet of also like
becoming a father now it's like i have
to let some of my old childhood stuff go
although i will introduce these kids at
least to the originals and the prequels
or we'll have to figure all that stuff
out um
but what movie would i reboot
reboot or let me think let me think for
a second i want to think of a great 80s
movie that we could bring back that
would be awesome
uh
well originally i went to total recall
because it's my favorite schwarzenegger
movie but they did reboot that the
reboot sucked he didn't even go to mars
i mean completely ridiculous get your
ass to mars great line of the original
then they don't even send them to mars
in this one um what would be a great 80s
reboot
i wonder if you could do you know i
remember the last time i said what's the
last funny movie you guys saw you guys
seen anything funny is there anything
funny anymore
anything
anchorman from like 20 years ago
anchorman uh i wonder if you could do
like a reboot of like an airplane you
know like i think we could use maybe
like a little more like slapstick sort
of ridiculous over-the-top comedy these
days i think something like that could
kind of work you know like you get some
of those references and some of the kind
of completely ridiculous stuff it seems
like we need more of that like just more
like in your face
smackdown comedy i think something like
that would work uh chuck says what are a
couple of the most important things you
want to pass along as a new parent
i mean i've hit on that a little bit
um
i think the main one is like
it's basically find your path
find it somehow i hope i will give these
kids i hope that we will give these kids
like some of the right tools
uh as jordan was saying to me the other
night like that we will put up the walls
that you're not allowed to bash right
through and that and they will bang
their heads
in them and occasionally they'll maybe
crack them or something but they will
have given enough
sanity and clarity
and truth along the way
that they'll be able to figure out what
their path is
i hope uh well i can say one thing for
sure i hope they don't become a lefty
you know what i mean like what if i had
a kid who was a lefty like what if my
son comes home and he says i'm a girl
and i'm a
i'm a girl and i'm a uh
you know democrat
oh god
i'm thinking about this i'm starting to
freak
jacob how do you insulate yourself from
the news during off the grid you know it
can get really tough because sometimes
in some ways it's easy when we've gone
away so if i'm in literally like the
middle of nowhere in the rain forest
it's very very easy uh but there you
know when there were times when i was
home
like uh the year before last when covid
was was really going nuts and you
couldn't go anywhere so we basically
just hunkered down
uh no it was that last year or the year
before yeah it was last year to two
years ago right when the midst the cove
it was nuts so we couldn't go anywhere
we just kind of hunkered down at home
um you know but i was still like if i
would wander out to the store or
whatever tvs are everywhere now which
kind of sucks like you're always
inundated with information billboards
that are digital showing you information
uh you walk past the store and they've
got cnn on or whatever it might be you
go to the gym you know over the years it
was tough like if i went to the gym um
you know they have tvs everywhere and
they don't have audio on necessarily but
you're seeing headlines so i would
always wear my hat real low and i'd kind
of never look up like it it becomes
difficult it really does but i've never
had in all the years
i've never had anything really major
blown to me like no one has you know
walked up to me and just said this
happened or that happened i've managed
to do it um
i guess it'll be pretty easy this year
uh we'll we'll have family here but
we're really just gonna kind of kind of
stick here and focus on family and just
our lives so i think this will probably
in some ways be the easiest of all of
them even when we've gone to resorts or
wherever you know sometimes uh you know
you go sit down for breakfast and they
either bring you the newspaper or they
bring you some
print out of what's going on in the
world
so it can be it can be tricky but we've
we've managed to do it and i hope i know
many of you i've seen a lot of comments
in the locals community i know a lot of
you are going to do some degree of off
the grid probably not for a month
maybe for a weekend or just
maybe you'll stick with email or
whatever for work but not do the social
media thing i really think it's how
we'll get off this stuff i really do i
think it's how we reset this stuff i
just i just fundamentally believe it
eric erica says dave if something
massive happens in august and your
people need you would you come in and
chat what if we promise extra guacamole
i do appreciate the extra guacamole
what if something no
you know like what could happen that
would look if if if say the nuclear bomb
dropped somewhere what am i gonna do
what do you need to see me for you know
honestly
you know what are we going to do
you'll be okay for a couple days without
me or you'll be incinerated
in which case
you know
um i don't think i would come back for
anything i can't imagine you know one
thing we've discussed um you know and i
should say that uh we do have a way
david does off the grid for the most
part he's not big on social media anyway
but we do have like an emergency burner
phone that if a family member needed to
get us if there was a major health
emergency
that kind of stuff that we're able to to
be uh gotten in touch with um
but you know if if i can't imagine a
political event or a current news event
that would bring me back the whole point
is to ignore it no matter what so it's
like again if biden goes down or
literally a war starts or you know one
thing we would need to know and we
actually did discuss this one somewhat
seriously is you know miami especially
south florida we get hurricanes here
like serious hurricanes so i don't want
to not know that a hurricane is a coming
or that a hurricane is a bruin they're
always a coming or a bruin and so we
would need to know that so we have told
people you can contact david if we are
going to be in the eye of the storm like
if i'm on my way to the you know oz
because of twister it's like we would
like to know about that but but that's
pretty much it uh chuck says who's the
more who's more nervous to be a parent
you or david um
i would say he's more nervous because
because he's doing all like the real
stuff right now that you know i'm really
focused on all of this and after today i
can kind of put the work stuff behind me
and i can get a little more involved but
he's been doing the bottles he's been
getting the breast milk he's been doing
the uh the strollers and
all of the baby beds and the changing
stations and the diapers and all that
stuff
and it's like you think about it if you
think about it this way guys you take
all the crying and the pooping and the
screaming and now we're gonna add a kid
into that it's a lot
come on you still love that joke you've
heard that five times but i don't think
i've said it on the show yet you know i
have i have said
wow you all just
yes dave you've told that stupid joke
you all just looked at me at the same
time and going we're getting off the
grid i've had just about enough of your
nonsense
um all right guys quick radio reset then
i'm just going to make one or two
announcements and then i think we'll
wrap it up we've got about an hour and a
half i think that's i think that's more
than enough uh for today um if you have
not joined us already this is the one
day you can do it uh to get three months
free off the annual subscription
reubenreport.com support and join us in
the locals community and yeah we will
post when uh when baby number one is
born and all that uh good stuff um i
also want to take a moment right now um
well first let's do uh i'm gonna do in
the reverse order uh one thing that
happened this year that actually was not
great was actually probably the saddest
moment for me this year uh is that my my
good friend bob saget legendary comedian
host of
uh america's funniest home videos and
danny tanner on full house bob passed
away out of nowhere
and uh it was really bob had become a
great friend of mine out of nowhere
he
one day i was when i finally started
doing stand-up again a couple years ago
in l.a i was at the comedy store which
is like the spot in hollywood and i was
in the small room upstairs because i
didn't want to do anything major yet i
didn't make a big announcement i just
wanted to kind of get my chops again and
i was upstairs and i got a message on
twitter after
from a girl named kelly and she said hey
i'm actually downstairs right now you
may know my husband bob saget he's
performing downstairs you're upstairs
i'm a big fan i'd love to meet you uh we
the four of us went out to dinner we
quickly hit it off bob and kelly became
two of our best friends
uh in los angeles uh and you know bob
passed away out of nowhere uh it was in
december right when we got here i was at
a bar with michael we were doing shows
it was that first week that we were back
doing shows um and we were sitting at a
bar and michael i saw his phone while we
were sitting there and he kind of turned
it away because i don't think he wanted
me to see it while we were just sitting
there right there but i saw it and uh
then everyone at the bar we were at a
mexican place and it was packed and i
kid you not over the next five or ten
minutes i saw every single person at the
bar looking at their phone
people very upset blah blah blah anyway
it turned out a couple people recognized
me we started talking we i ended up
buying shots for everybody at the bar
and everyone's telling their bob saget
stories and uh
i miss bob terribly he was he was really
just a great man and i thought if i
could just do one little extra tribute
to my friend who uh who we lost this
year uh here's a moment of bob on the
show to be a good comic you have to have
a ton of [ __ ] like you have to have all
this pain and all this angst and all
this stuff but then at some point
you got to conquer it because otherwise
it will conquer you and that's why so
many comics die of drug overdoses and
all this other stuff
are dying
yeah but if you can own it then you
could be 62
and i'm gonna be doing i don't know if
i'm gonna be doing stand up at 90 but
i'll be doing forms of it yeah you know
you couldn't stop even if you wanted to
right i could not stop working
i i i just directed this movie benjamin
which i'll talk about at length in the
third hour of our interview
but but i i have to leave after hour too
but you're welcome i'm going to stay
we're just going to keep going it's just
going to be me and the camera but but i
i love working without it i
i'm an artist
and it sounds so fruity pebbles to say
that but i just am and i always will be
and i'll be making whether it be
directing or writing or performing i
love acting there's no limit as long as
you can stand and walk and bend and
remember things you know
you know yeah not fall into an open
trunk
right the memory one goes first because
now there's guys on broadway that are
using uh
isps earwigs yeah i was gonna say uh ib
ib what's the intercontinental ibm
missiles yeah not those that's that's a
difference no no that has been known and
i hopefully will uh live long enough
that at 92 years old i'll be on broadway
and i'll have an airway again and
they'll feed me the lines and i don't
care
ah i miss you bobby i love you um so
that was that was kind of the one down
thing for the year uh and on a quick
little transition there i don't know how
you totally transition out of that uh i
have to turn to my left for a moment uh
and thank this guy over here uh my
producer michael this is his last day
with the reuben report we hired michael
uh
two and a half years ago it's hard to
remember any of this thing without you
um and we thought he was gonna kind of
do some
pr for us and maybe some graphics for us
and very very quickly uh michael
basically took over the entire show and
became the producer and joined me on all
of my uh adventures and became my tour
manager in many ways became my manager
and became a friend and all of those
things and uh and he did screw that up
just now so that's it michael actually
you're not paying you so we were going
to pay you to the end of the day
but that's it um
but he has done incredible work here and
helped us build the team that that's in
this room phoenix and connor and michael
put so much of this together and i think
so many of the you know the reason that
the show is continually growing and
every month basically we break our
records across views and downloads and
listens and i think part of the reason
that i'm better at what i do is that
michael helped get a lot of the clerical
stuff that i was dealing with and the
nonsense out of the way uh he is staying
in miami he is uh moving on to he just
had a great opportunity i don't think
he's angry at me you're not angry i mean
are you okay he's not angry at me no i'm
very happy for him david's very happy
for him he's going to do awesome things
maybe we'll collaborate on some things
in the future uh we shall see uh so uh i
felt it was worthy of telling you good
people and uh yeah we're gonna we're
gonna add some team members and do a
whole bunch of other stuff uh so the
other thing is i will be back uh on
september 1st as you know uh the locals
studio will be officially built and
ready to roll uh very special guest who
will bring me back on the grid then i'm
going to make a couple other
announcements in september we were
thought maybe we could do a couple
things today
but i don't want i don't want to tease
too much actually at the moment um but
this is just the beginning again i
always say to david at this time of the
year i'm just like man we're just back
at the beginning again and that is how i
always feel it's like every year that
we've done this we've managed to grow
this thing i think we're doing i
honestly think maybe it's not for me to
say but i think i'm doing the best work
that i've ever done which is in large
part because uh because of these guys
and uh and it's and it's hugely
it's bigly because of you guys
to go on that tour meet you guys and say
dave you helped keep me sane throughout
this and the love that i get from you
guys and i do these meet and greets and
literally hundreds of people waiting
just to freaking shake my hand and hug
me or smile at me or say something to me
the amount of people that have given us
baby gifts or tequila i prefer the
tequila but you've also given us baby
gifts and hand painted drawings and like
just
i am uh i am humbled and honored and i
thank you for uh allowing me to be part
of your life i hope you miss me a little
bit but i also hope that you take a
little time off in in whatever your own
way is over august it's like if there's
ever a month to do it it's august right
and remember it all kicks up again in in
the fall right we're gonna have this
midterm all these elections all the
craziness
but if you can maybe take your foot off
the pedal a little bit too
i really think that that's not only how
we'll stay sane but it is how we'll win
this thing because there's a lot of
other stuff out there so as much as i
love doing all this like i was even
thinking about it this morning like i
will miss being in studio on monday i
love what i'm doing this has nothing to
do with not loving it not thinking it's
important or anything else but there's
also other things that are important too
so uh
well i guess the next time you see me
i'll be a dad
and maybe some of you will be too i
don't know what you guys are doing
but we will be doing a live stream with
drinks later for the locals community so
you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com if you want to
have some drinks with us later and then
i'm cooking steaks for these guys
michael we're letting you go with the
steak will that be all right i got a big
freaking filet mignon it's like this
it's huge huge oh and one other thing
thank you for mentioning that uh we will
have content all month so one of the
things i try to balance in august
is should we put up pre-recorded stuff
or just go silent altogether and one of
the things is and this is like a little
insider baseball but i think it's
important for you to know how how i
think about this stuff and how we come
to these conclusions you know if we put
up nothing on youtube it's one thing for
me not to tweet it's one thing for me
not to put anything on instagram or
facebook whatever
if we put nothing up on youtube over the
month the algorithm actually kind of
pushes you out
so over the years we've usually put up
one interview or one clip a week two
clips a week something like that and
then what happens is when we come back
in september the algorithm has so far
pushed us out like people aren't
watching because they see oh wait you
guys have got all these people watching
suddenly nobody's watching for a month
the algorithm can just basically
unperson you
so one of the things that we felt was
really important is i really really want
to keep the momentum that we've got
going so we did shoot some really funny
stuff so first off i shot a couple
interviews uh you're going to get an
interview with adam carolla uh we've got
jetta diabyla a couple other people uh
robert kiyosaki like we've got some
really really fun interviews but but
here's the other part um we did all of
these sort of generic intros for crazy
clips like here's something i'm off the
grid but here's something that the crazy
ladies of the view did or here's joy
reid going bananas or the alien
apocalypse has begun or the world ended
or joe biden's dead or whatever i just
shot like 50 of these things so we could
keep showing you clips so i will not
know what's going on i have handed this
to phoenix okay he's young he's a
padawan but i said to him can you pick
the clips and then i said to connor can
you edit me in
i will not know what's going on but the
clips will keep coming that way the
channel stays strong so that when we get
into september so don't worry if if you
want clips and silly stuff it will all
be there i just won't have any clue
what's going on so that is the plan for
august and uh that's all that i got to
say
about that so i thank you guys for being
part of the adventure
this is just the beginning enjoy the
rest of your summer
and uh as they say in that song see you
in september